albert pujols i don't know if you guys
know he's a baseball player baseball's a
sport in america
yeah kind of yeah and uh basically his
wife was getting brain surgery
and he clearly thought that she was
gonna die
and she ended up living
damn so he divorced her right afterwards
bad or good i think it's a good thing to
do talk to me look she's got a new lease
on life so now he's like look take half
my money and then go be free oh is she
getting caked up i'm sure it's a divorce
you're getting caked up somehow wow
hey you got you go live another life you
got a second chance why live a second
life married
i mean go live a second life albert
pujols is a good man oh he's doing this
for her for her that's a good spirit
he's a charitable guy that's a good do
you think that he was hoping that she
would die probably yeah i don't mean
maybe just forget that she was married
to him like the vow
but he just leaves right after yeah yeah
wait what's the vow i never saw that the
romantic movie i've seen
a wife gets uh amnesia and then the
husband stays with her until she
remembers everything oh is that with
adam sandler that's not like no it's
channing first dates 50 first dates i've
seen that same same to sam basically but
one is a comedy and one is more romantic
that 50 first day [ __ ] is mad funny
because does he smash day one i don't
think so cause like one day she's like i
don't really give head and he was like
yo
dumbass
i was sucking this dick crazy three days
ago when i took you on a [ __ ] canoe
that you can find out if the girl's
lying or not yeah yeah yeah yeah
tech window
my little tech window you know what i'm
saying what do you guys think about
alberto
i don't speak spanish oh i mean actually
but like alice only apparently is not
really the case yeah why not nah they've
been separated for a long time huh
the divorce just went through
yeah oh joseph he was doing this
how what what
what are you saying bro
what's the information
[Laughter]
tell us some things that's going on
so brain had a little case of the fuzzy
wuzzy
i think they just tried to cover that i
think so all right so what happened
i have rub yeah i got a split
so she went in there
her head was a little bit wonky
and they scooped out the wonky yeah and
then he just divorced her right right
then and there
a recent uh near certain hall of famer
conceded this uh that his timing was
awkward he said in the statement about
the divorce at the time he was awkward
this is why i realize this is not the
most this is not the most opportune time
with opening day approaching
and other faces opening day the day of
the surgery yeah
is that when they cut a [ __ ] skull
open to scoop out the fuzzy wuzzy
[ __ ]
the wonky bear in there
yeah
i think it is
all right is any more vehicle you want
to read us
he was just he was just tired of the
lawyers dragging their feet
and so he's like yo get this [ __ ] done
with
that's what it was really yeah
[Laughter]
all right well if it's not that crazy
and it's time for him to get a divorce i
guess it's pretty good
shall we move on to the other story
wait real quick the reason he didn't get
divorced earlier because he thought he
could keep half his money if she died
that's what they were just accepting
more likely yeah but now did she's
survived
right
it's quite a simple surgery when you
think about it that's the other thing
anytime you divorce or break up with
someone it's always after something
eventually you know like oh i was in a
car accident two months ago like he
broke up with me two days after my
birthday like there's always some [ __ ]
happening yeah do you think she got the
brain cancer from not sucking his deck
of a lot
i think we need to make wives know that
i think it's important remember they
said that if you eat out girls you get
throat cancer yeah oh hey yeah yeah
that's what happened
michael douglas oh he was eating that a
girl from wales they're full of kinds of
those girls he's the same guy who likes
the hamsters up his ass nope that's
richard gear that's switch again how
white this is
if
you were married
to cindy crawford okay you'd want some
gerbils in your wanky box
[Laughter]
wouldn't you
i guess wouldn't you want your wouldn't
you want some jars yeah i know
in your toblerone maker
[Applause]